[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let me bring in tim mcmahon the espn nba
reporter who's done a great job keeping
an eye on the james harden situation and
uh
tim thanks for joining us if i had you
on yesterday at this time
what would you have said was going to
happen in houston with james harden
well i would have said that a trade is
closer to happening than not
um you know obviously
he i i think the trade was close to
being completed
or they knew that they were close to a
trade whether it was going to be philly
or brooklyn
and then harden's performance tuesday
night by performance i don't mean
5-16 from the floor i mean the post-game
press conference was basically his way
of saying hey
i'm pretty much to the other side of the
bridge so let me just burn this
and you know you guys can figure out the
rest do you think he knew he was going
to be traded it was
a trade was imminent with what he
because i said the same thing yesterday
morning when i heard that
i said that's his exit interview he's
basically saying see ya
do you think he knew at that time that
he was going to be traded
well i think he knew that it was
very close to happening and he wanted to
make sure
it happened you know so again whether it
was philly or brooklyn
he was fine with either plays obviously
he want to get out of houston those are
the top two teams on his list
and i think that was his way of saying
hey i'm done here
you figure out which one of those two
teams i'm going to but uh
i'm done with the rockets it's a tricky
legacy with james harden i don't know if
he cares about his legacy
but you wrote a column on this exact
topic here
how do you think houston will remember
james harden
that it is it's tricky complicated
whatever you want to say
look with all due respect to moses
malone i would say james harden is the
second best player in franchise history
behind only
hakeem olajuwon obviously the huge
difference there zakima lajwan delivered
two championships to houston
hardin was never able to get the rockets
even to the nba finals and
i mean it didn't work out with dwight
howard that went up in smoke
chris paul went up in smoke even quicker
russell westbrook his old friend from la
and the old okc teammate one year and
they were ready to
both uh you know go other places
and it and then just the way it ended
obviously
that's going to be bitter you know at
the same at the same time
it was eight mostly great years
individually brilliant years from james
harden
um gave the rockets a chance to at least
be contenders for most that time and
it's funny because rockets fans for so
much that time
were kind of defending james harden who
was the superstar
the rest of the league's fans loved to
hate hated his style
playing all that rockets fans spent so
much time
kind of getting these guys back and
their reward is
no championship parade and then pretty
much a slap in the face on the way out
of town
we'll talk about the nets and getting
james harden and what that means but
how did the rockets do in this trade
well look this obviously
was about trying to set themselves up
for a rebuild
and the rockets did not get the young
franchise cornerstone that they
insisted they needed to get in a james
harden deal they could have
they could have had ben simmons but they
made the decision that they would rather
have just i mean a historic bundle of
unprotected first round picks and so
look those picks kevin durant james
harden kyrie irving will be long
gone the rockets are still going to be
making picks that are the new york or
the uh the brooklyn net
so i think you look at the just the
bundle of pics and say hey
you know that's a historic hall and i i
think
realistically as far as a team entering
a rebuild that's a good return
but i don't even know if victor oladipo
is going to be there by season's end
that oh yeah right no question about
that look victor oladipo
you can tell why they flip karis levert
for for victor oladipo i think the first
thing you look at is the contracts
uh levert is owed 36 plus mill over the
you know two seasons past this one
oladipo's uh an expiring contract so
they kind of get a chance to
uh bring all the people in you know take
a look at them figure out hey is this a
guy that
we want to pay this all season he's
going to get paid because there's
you know that free agency uh class has
been picked pretty thin
or is it a guy who maybe he might not
even be there after the trade deadline
maybe they flip him again
and you know continue to kind of add to
their pick stockpile
i like what the pacers did i like karis
laverde a lot
and i got a chance to see him a lot when
you know all that
when kyrie was injured and that younger
team kind of came to life
there and even uh jared allen in
cleveland
he's an energy guy team guy um
you know maybe we don't need rim
protectors but i thought
this is sort of those you know after the
dust settles people go oh that's right
you know indiana looks pretty good
um you know when warren comes back they
have turner they have sabonis they have
brogden
you know they have a pretty good nucleus
not depth but they got a good nucleus
and then with cleveland getting jared
allen
i think he's a you know a bona fide
starting player who
can put up a double double every night
your thoughts on it
i think both of those teams that were
brought into the deal
really benefited and for indiana victor
oladipo was not going to be back there
next year so this is a chance to get a
guy who can be a you know 20-ish point
per game
score you know the rockets did not
consider him to be a franchise
cornerstone and i think that's accurate
but you know at a place like indiana i
think he fits very well with malcolm
bragg and
that back court you know with with
sabonis is really kind of their
franchise
player i think it's it's you know the
contract is reasonable for a guy who
is has proven he can be as productive as
he has been
and then i thought it was a great deal
for cleveland when you look at the back
court they're building around they kind
of hope
those young players you know the the sex
land back court which is one of the
great nicknames
in the league they hope those guys can
kind of develop into a
blazers east sort of backward and
there's been really encouraging signs of
progress from them but if you're going
to start
two smallest scoring guards
you better get a really good rim
protector behind them you
know they will benefit from having a a
lob threat
and look jared allen they will pay him
this summer but at 22 he really fits
with
what they're building in cleveland all
right let's get to the nets now
on and off the court we're talking to
tim mcmahon espn nba
reporter uh where's kyrie irving and how
does he fit into
all of this uh last i saw him he was on
zoom
okay all right you know look i i think
that is
reasonable to look at this trade in some
ways as
kyrie irving insurance and uh you know
the the nets
really amped up what they were willing
to offer in terms of the draft
compensation that's what got this
over the finish line they amped that up
since kyrie has been
you know whatever you want to call it a
wall um
here's the deal kevin durant even coming
off the achilles
is a bona fide superstar in his prime
you basically got two more guaranteed
years with him and then he can become a
free agent so you
have to earn unless you really want to
if you're the nets
maximize your opportunity to win a
championship with him
you need to have not just a co-star but
a
another superstar to pair with him to do
that they bring in james harden
he's now say what you want he's a dude
who can officially put up 35 points in
eight or ten assists
there ain't too many of those dudes
walking the face of the earth and
honestly at this point what they get
from kyrie you can almost look at it as
as bonus when james harden
makes his debut with the nets is kyrie
irving on the floor
no because first of all i don't know
when and i'm not sure anybody with
nets even knows when kyrie is going to
decide that okay this little
sabbatical's over i'm coming back to
work
but when he even if he just if he called
them this morning said hey i'm coming
back
the league office is like okay great
kyrie well guess what you're going to
have to sit for a while because
you blatantly violated the league's
health and safety protocols just like
hardin had to
you know he didn't end up missing the
game because he helped get a game
postponed the right but we're so
casual about this tim like kyrie irving
is
is missing right in front of our very
eyes like
it's it's bizarre but you know what i
mean kyrie
kind of obviously he's a guy who marches
to the beat of his own drum
and really the confusing thing is like i
understood
with hard harden let's be honest he was
trying to be as big of a pain in the ass
as possible
because he wanted to get the hell out of
houston i don't i don't know
what kyrie's intent is here because
he's where he wanted to be he chose to
go to brooklyn
he's playing with kevin durant the guy
he wanted to team up with
so this is obviously not a it's not a
situation where
he's unhappy about his employer so
you know at some point kyrie irving will
offer
at least his version of an explanation i
certainly can't give it to you
yeah he probably won't he probably will
feel like he doesn't need to
if i'm he'll say a lot of words and then
we'll have to figure out whether to
actually meet anything
how do you think the lakers view this
trade
should they be nervous honestly i don't
think i think the lakers and you saw
or you heard anthony davis after last
night's game he basically yeah
looks good on paper we'll see how it
looks on the floor i think the lakers
feel like if they're healthy
and if they're playing up to their
potential it doesn't matter who they
run up against i mean lebron in year 18
still looks like if not the best player
in the league he's definitely in that
conversation
and anthony davis is in that
conversation they've got a knife they
upgraded the supporting cast around
those guys
this is after they cruised to the
playoffs to a championship last year
i don't think the lakers are losing any
sleep over what brooklyn did
um maybe they meet in the finals maybe
they don't
but again it's not disrespect to the
nets i just
think the lakers probably look at this
situation say hey we're the best team in
the league and nothing has changed
did the 76ers win yesterday
i i un i think doc rivers won yesterday
i think ben simmons won yesterday uh i
boo
i believe if this was up to daryl murray
james harden would be
in philadelphia and ben simmons would be
in houston now
um but i look the sixers have played
very well
this season the simmons embiid thing
with the with the new
pieces around them the spacing around
them looks like it's a compatible duo
uh again and i i i know it was not
anything close to a consensus
decision within that sixes organization
that trading
young ben simmons for 31 year old james
harden plus whatever you had to throw in
the deal
would have been a good move for the
sixers so uh
i i think philly's just fine not having
gotten james hard
oh man if i talk to you in a month
with the nets what are we talking about
your guess is as good as mine look first
of all
again kyrie is just a wild card at this
point like even if he decides to come
back who knows
who knows with him he's obviously an
immense talent but he's not a teammate
you can count on
doesn't mean he's a bad person uh so you
know
he's done great things in the community
so on and so forth but
just in terms of an employee on a
basketball team he is completely
unreliable he's also ridiculously
talented and again whether they have
kyrie or not
james harden kevin durant the two
best scorers in the league on one team
the nets are going to score a ton of
points
they're going to win a lot of 135 128
type of games will they be able to play
good enough defense to
make a four series run through the
playoffs
i i'm i will believe that when i see it
i i don't think that we're looking at
the nets
suddenly as the no doubt favorites in
the eastern conference much less in the
nba
thank you tim for taking some time we
appreciate it good luck
appreciate you having me that's uh tim
mcmahon espn nba reporter